we had your wife Michelle on the show
and she had mentioned that for about 10
years of the marriage she really didn't
like you oh man um so asking for a
friend um how do you get back in good
graces again for a friend you got a pen
start taking notes let me just say this
uh it sure helps to be out of the white
house uh uh and uh to to have a little
more time with her right you know what
also helps though about children and
yeah I don't know about your spouse
Michelle
when when our girls were growing up
that was priority number one two three
and four of course and so I I did not
fully appreciate I think as as engaged
of a father as I was
the degree of stress and tension for her